[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute mit mit samira was back anbieten
heute ganz genau wir machen so was wie
eine linzer torte aber mit zitronen ein
italienisches rezept großvater allem
ohne das ist ein mürbeteig ich habe den
nutzen ein bisschen verfeinert oder
werde ihnen gleich verfeinern mit
wandern so das ist wirklich so eine
linse dort erinnert und dann richtig
leckere zitronencreme rein für den
mürbeteig brauche ich 400 gramm mehl 200
gramm zucker 200 gramm butter 100 gramm
an die werden gleich noch gemahlen
zweier vanille extrakt und zitronen
abriss amirante schon mal die butter
hier eingeben
perfekt übernehmen
und du darfst du noch zucker dazugeben
also butter und zucker vergessen haben
eine prise salz die hole ich noch und du
kannst ja schonmal vanille extrakt
reinmachen genau eine prise salz ist
nicht schlimm
ok dann kurz verrühren maxi
zitronenkuchen was denke dings kurven
stimmt bei unserem becker beim markt da
will sie immer die linzer torte von dort
ok sanieren
wir kommen hier ist auch eine stimme das
ist vom eis ist es nicht schlimm
und was wir können während das berührt
schon mal die mandeln mal okay und da
nehme ich immer ganz gerne ganze mandeln
weil es aroma einfach intensiver
schmeckt machst du dann reiben mit der
feinen reibe kräftig an terrain wird er
daran geschraubt
so kann es da oben auch festhalten
feucht ist
ich mach weiter
ich kenne ja auch schon mal die
zitronenschale ableiten da einfach immer
darauf aufpassen dass die zitronenschale
dezember ist steht dann meist mit dabei
oder ihr könnt natürlich auch den
fachberater oder auf dem markt einfach
nachfrage
[Musik]
schmecken und akiko macht de-mail und
zitronenschale rein
und ich den mantel und ein römer 2
niedriger stufe ja schon raus hier kann
man jetzt einfach den teig kurz zu einer
kugel zusammen kneten
das ist auch schön weich wäre jetzt ganz
eingenommen haben
normalerweise nehme ich bei mir wird
immer nur weil aik den teig schön fine
macht und eigelb und eiweiß er härter
aber bei der linzer torte nimmt man ja
auch ganze eier und hier passt sind auch
echt ganz gut so und jetzt mal hier auf
dem teller muss nicht perfekt sein
schoss ihr team genauso würdet ihr ja
viel zu langsam kühlen also machen mit
dem stand platz so geht es nämlich
schneller das ist der mama trick je
flacher umso schneller kühlt er fünfmal
deckel drauf und ab in den kühlschrank
aber wir müssen jetzt nicht warten wir
können jetzt schon direkt die zitronen
krenn zu bringen
für die zitronencreme verwende ich 300
gramm 11 40 gramm zitronensaft und den
abrieb dazu drohnen 2 eigelbe 50 gramm
zucker und 35 gramm stärke finden jetzt
auch wieder zuerst zitronen und reiben
die schale ab wenn ihr keine feinen
reibe habt könnt ihr übrigens auch mit
einem sparschäler diese gelbe schale
abschirmt einfach mit zur creme geben
und später dann wieder rausnehmen das
geht auch noch die falsche farbe schnell
du kleine künstlerin echt schön gemalt
starten bild gesehen und dann einfach
wir hatten fotos einem vertrag also die
guckt sich dann einfach auf dem handy
fotos sagen von pferden tobt sie sich
aus und nochmals frei hand aber drauf
gemalt nicht toll da wird sich eine
freundin freuen
ja klar das sieht nicht mehr aus weil es
hat eine ganze stadt ist könnte ich
nicht mal
toll zumal wenn du willst kannst du ja
schon mal die milch in den topf geben
erst mal nur die hälfte
so ein bisschen mal ja es reicht schon
und jetzt hier alle anderen zutaten kurz
verrühren das ist stärke dass das geld
da gebe ich dir so ein teigs aber wenn
ich im kleinen herumgehen aufnehmen
super ich gebe noch meine zitronenschale
dazu also wir lieben beide zu tun oder
schon ja ich esse keine todesfälle geben
wir auch komplett dazu wir wollen
nämlich den vollen zitronengeschmack und
ich weiß nicht warum meine freundin des
komisch ist
da gibt es noch zucker rein ich gebe das
ja und das ist im prinzip wie ein level
curt aber mit milch das heißt das ganze
wird jetzt ein bisschen flüssiger und
nicht ganz so sauer wie lemon gehört
jetzt kurz vor röhren samira genau so
dass man jetzt etwa 40 millimeter 40
gramm jetzt schön gemacht münchen frei
das gibt es in schwärmen die mit der
stärke unten was anderes machen oder
aber es gibt ganz schnell koch die
strecke setzt sich nur manchmal am boden
gerne fest und jetzt darf die restlich
dazu
[Musik]
super was sagst du weiter nicht schlimm
der papa macht mehr saubere in der küche
jetzt wichtig immer rühren und bei
mittel hoher hitze erwärmen
damit ist der pudding oder die creme
damit die einmal aufkochen kann
aufpassen dass der boden nicht amt und
daher nicht auf die höchste stufe schön
langsam und ebenso lang sauber
ok
richtig schöner pudding und beispiel was
damit er jetzt ein bisschen gelber wird
wenn wir dann farblich ein bisschen zu
hell
dann nehmen wir machen jetzt auch mal
heraus nehmen wir curcuma dessen gewirkt
aber dann schmeckt eigentlich kaum
nein das ist natürliche
lebensmittelfarbe mein lebensmittelfarbe
kann man auch nehmen aber das ist mir
ganz natürliche lebensmittelfarbe muss
mal hier rein und jetzt röhren jetzt die
farbe wird kraft
[Musik]
jetzt ist es schön gerechtes abkommen
was ich bin gespannt was du sagst
[Musik]
ja sag mal deine tränen und die
zitronencreme die füllen wir jetzt um in
einem flachen teller streichen sie
vorher noch durch ein haar sieht falls
doch noch blümchen drin sind von der
stärke hatte vom ei zum beispiel decken
sehr auf der oberfläche direkt mit
frischhaltefolie ab und warten jetzt
eigentlich nur noch ein paar minuten bis
der mürbeteig schön kalt ist und bedarf
später ruhig noch ein bisschen lauwarm
sein okay
[Musik]
erst kurz den teig nochmals durchkneten
und wenn es ganz schnell gehen muss
stellen wir den teig einfach ins
kühlfach also in den gefrierschrank für
zehn minuten geht auch aber eine stunde
kühlschrank ist eigentlich immer ein
bisschen praktisch wir haben jetzt
schnell schnee ja geht auch und jetzt
ein bisschen mehl auf die silikon matte
streuen
ein bisschen noch
das brauche ich noch ein bisschen oben
drauf weil der teig geben noch nicht
ganz durch gekühlt ist ich komme jetzt
zeige ich dann habe ich das immer aus
rolle okay für die radfahrer dann immer
mit der palette darunter dann kann ich
ihn schön drehen und reißt da auch noch
arbeitslos ein bisschen kann ich sowieso
schon wegnehmen und dann eine gute
handvoll brauche ich nämlich für die
streifen oben drauf jetzt nehmen wir mal
die tat form und dann gucke ich immer
das ist reicht am rand das reicht dann
aufholen und der rest von kuchenteig
entgelt den kühlschränken
genau das ist auch noch ein bisschen
warm muss man dazu sagen ist es dann
einfach schwieriger man sieht er reist
am schneller arbeitet ist ja gar nicht
schlimm
man kann es ja ganz gut dran stücke
der handschuh jetzt nämlich einfach eine
palette und dann fahre ich von der mitte
nach außen so entlang problem also hier
ist die mitte und die mache ich nicht
seitlich weil es um struktur den teig
rein sondern nach außen okay hier hinten
aufpassen
ja es war jetzt streichen wir hier die
creme rein
ich habe dir schlüssel fest und darf zu
erreichen
okay da hab ich zu einem teig
saubermachen mit dem es ihnen ja dass
dies so groß oder romane kleine palette
so eine kleine mini bringt die palette
der coach und was wären du das machst
ich stell dich mal kurz zur seite
hierhin ich kann ich schon mal den
übrigen teig ausrollen dem kalten klar
freuen kann
hallo aufwachen machen wir zusammen so
und jetzt noch das gitter normalerweise
würde ich den tag ein bisschen dicker
lassen amazon ihrer hätte gerne und das
ist ja genau und deswegen dürfen wird
damit gleich auf der silicon mutter
schneiden denn wie man hier sieht hat es
ist doch ganz stumpf und ganz dick
schneidet nicht deswegen können wir hier
drauf benutzen ansonsten pizza rat auf
keinen fall besser rates viel zu scharf
und weil schwarz damit perfekt wird
mache ich das hier hilft mit hölzern
[Musik]
wenn jetzt den ersten streifen eben die
mitte legen oder direkt nebendran ein
paar machen wir so untermann park wäre
okay das um gittermuster entsteht
wenn wir schon ab klasse 7 a
[Musik]
und gefällst du dir so wirklich aber
fakt dass jetzt nur wollte den teig
haben
ok also soll man nicht noch im land drum
herum legen ist mir egal und wir gucken
mal mehr aus warum also dann darfst du
den teig haben und unsere tat die kommt
jetzt in den backofen
ihr seht es war wirklich super einfach
also zubereitungszeit hatten wir echt
nicht fehlen die meiste zeit mal
geschwitzt
somit ist ein paar filme zitat
konditionen backofen wird so gebacken
und dann probieren wir zusammen okay
normalerweise hätte ich den tag noch
benutzt für einen rand arbeiten
[Musik]
jänner gletscherschnee ich mache die
eröffnung großer schatz und jetzt suche
ich beim bauernhof da viel elan genauso
mit papa im garten gesucht aber partei
war schon damals gab es jetzt noch ganz
frisch ein bisschen haben das abkühlen
lassen und lässt sich halt immer gut
aussehen aber der gerettete tier sprang
ich sage auch gleich warum aber eher
strengen jetzt mal ja ja da will auch
noch mal alles wissen und wie schmeckt
die tat also jetzt ist er noch frisch
und bestimmt das ermöglicht auch noch
ziemlich fest am nächsten tag schmeckt
sogar also eigentlich müsste man sie
über nacht stehen lassen
da guck mal ich hab eine linzer torte
für dieses mal eigentlich auch nicht
frisch sondern lässt zuerst nur 23 tage
ruhen so entfalten sich die aromen und
der teig wird natürlich weiß und von tag
zu tag wird die dann saftiger und
mierdorf zuerst probieren
ok angela und sagen was gebacken
aber du musst ehrlich sein wie es
schmeckt erlag
und wenn sie nicht schmeckt dann sagst
du es auch immer geld und jetzt
probieren
[Musik]
das rezept ist übrigens ein
italienisches rezepte ich glaube ich
wird nur nächsten mal mehr zitronensaft
nehmen damit soll ja nicht aber es kann
auch sein dass von einem vorspiel
richtig gut was manches erinnert an
ich wollte mal was auch italienisches
gemacht wird sich das passt da die pasta
zara
ich weiß was du meinst werd mal so eine
oster gemacht aber da war grease oder
weil irgendwas weitergelaufen
unglaublich gelaufen
mit den jetzt am nächsten tag schön zart
durchgezogen
ich schreibe ich auch im rezept etwas
mehr zitronensaft rein äußerlicher finde
ich immer gut aber cool der mega einfach
gemacht also wie die verlierer wären
technik viele tolle partie
was macht ihr denn und samira hat was
für euch gebacken obwohl ich jetzt auch
mal kurz ich zeige es euch und dann
kannst du siehst du mal was diablo für
uns gemacht hat aber ich muss danke
sagen habe ich mal ein bild von dir
kommen sie mir auch dazu von euch beiden
haben mich einweisen nicht reinlassen
und ein zurück zu mir
spaghetti
aber auch noch tragen
wir machen noch zu viert 111 kommt noch
das törtchen
[Musik]
[Applaus]